hey what's going on it still burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday November 18th 2018 what's going
on how are ya as you can tell I am not
using my [ __ ] mixer or anything right
now I left everything at home I'm doing
a little staycation with my wife
staycation all I ever wanted and we're
having a great time all right
and if there's other married people out
there I highly recommend it it's cheap
it's a great way to reconnect with your
spouse and be like oh yeah we love each
other
remember I totally forgot you know you
get all caught up in your job you got
the kid the the [ __ ] termites took
over your [ __ ] house whatever the
hell's going on in your world you can
just you start taking each other for
granted so we've been out here for a
couple days having a good time it's
weird that once you have a kid then you
go on a staycation you're loving it
but then you know your kids staying with
the relatives and then you miss your
kids you know I don't know whatever what
are you gonna do he is hilarious I
smoked a cigar last night right and I
didn't finish it so this morning I went
down to the the hotel pool which was
[ __ ] gigantic and I already had it in
my head that I was gonna do 10 laps
there and back counting his won and this
thing was like the point of biggest
[ __ ] pools I've ever been it was like
literally two and a half times the size
of you know even the average hotel pools
I mean the deep end was eight feet and
then 10 feet and this is an old school
like it had everything but a diving
board you know that's how old I am
I remember you'd go to a [ __ ] hotel
and not only did the hotel to have an
actual deep end you know because now you
go there things are like [ __ ] four
feet deep no diving is written all
around the whole pool but back in the
day man you [ __ ] show up and it was a
giant pool with the deep end they'd have
a [ __ ] diving board and you they
would just say man you want to break in
that could drown yourself you know we
have all the facilities out there for
you to succeed at just that so anyways I
went down there and I swam around and
like I always have to go like the length
of the pool underwater and like in order
to make it I had to come up to the
surface and then do the crawl really
quickly just to get to the little final
like four feet and I was so goddamn out
of breath and I still get like freaked
out when I'm in pools and [ __ ] because I
saw jaws at a certain age it's why I
can't go in the [ __ ] ocean and I was
still thinking like well there's a
there's a [ __ ] alligator you know
some douchebag drug dealer you know or
[ __ ] boxer or rich parson you know
those are the people you know some
[ __ ] Saudi Arabian [ __ ] prince
buys a house in the Hollywood Hills you
know they always they always like
[ __ ] of a pet cheetah or some [ __ ]
you know then everybody has the exotic
cats and now this dude's got to top
everybody else and he gets a [ __ ]
alligator and the thing gets loose and
then slips into the pool I had that like
that's the [ __ ] that I think about when
I go swimming it's [ __ ] especially in
a pool that big where I felt like I was
in a lake
but anyway Soni ends up coming down
right and I told it was like 10 in the
morning and I still had like a little
bit of that cigar left I go I might go
back to the room smoke the rest set
cigar she goes gross at 10:00 in the
morning you're gonna smoke a cigar 10:00
in the morning she goes we were you a
[ __ ] crime boss I really married a
[ __ ] hilarious woman but anyways
before I tell you more about my
staycation all I ever wanted I got to
tell you about the the Patrice oh the
7th annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit
is going to be Tuesday February 19th
2019 at 7 p.m. at the City Center
Theater where we always do it New York
New York 131 West 55th Street
this is the most important show that I
do every year I'm gonna thank everyone
before you guys even buy tickets we've
sold out every single year and I I can't
even begin to get into it because I'll
get too emotional but like the level
with which that you guys have you know
just by buying tickets have helped out
you know his family and everything like
they've really been taken care of and
are totally been blown away by the
generosity of you guys showing up and
then of course all the comedians who've
done the show for us throughout the
years that you know I mean it's a
benefit it's a free show for them and
they always take time out of their
schedule we've had people [ __ ] fly in
so anyways this is our lineup this year
all right we have the [ __ ] amazing
now I can't do adjectives for everybody
because I'm gonna run out I'm gonna run
out okay everybody on here is a [ __ ]
monster we got big Jay oakerson we got
Gary Gulman Jim Gaffigan Michelle wolf
rich Voss will host it as always safest
sounds Chris red with more names to be
announced possible big time special
guest is on the fence this is just like
its own always and it always comes off
it's like a [ __ ] high school reunion
and boss does the intros he [ __ ]
trashes everybody and it's sort of like
it's his fun stand-up show slash roasts
well we're just out there just giving
each other [ __ ] and it's awesome so
anyways like I said to Satan apartment
sevens now you're probably well how do I
get how do I buy tickets well there's
three ways to get tickets you go to WWE
York no sorry w NY City Center org or
you can call city tickets at two one two
five eight one one two one two and their
hours are Monday through Saturday noon
to 8 p.m. Sunday noon to 7:30 or you can
go to the box office 131 West 55th
Street between 6th and
seventh avenue and their hours are
Monday through Saturday noon to 8:00 in
Sunday noon to 7:30 and when the [ __ ] to
these tickets go live about of course I
don't have that goddamn information in
front of me but I know it's it's 9 p.m.
Pacific time
this Monday when you're listening to it
today I should say the 19th I guess
right did I say at the top of the
podcast that it was Monday November 18th
it's Monday November 19th
so anyways sorry for the long all that
information but this really is this this
is this is the the biggest gig that I do
every year because you know he just was
such a special person and his family is
so [ __ ] awesome and uh you know
anyways alright let me get back let me
get back to the podcast all right oh
wait I have other [ __ ] to talk about
here so Oh Billy announcer I'm loving
life right now dude like staycations
three days that's all I [ __ ] need I'm
German Irish I don't need to [ __ ] lay
around for ten days you give me three
[ __ ] days
or I can just hang out and [ __ ] with
my [ __ ] absolutely gorgeous wife she
really is a beauty and just we've been
laughing our asses off just having a
great [ __ ] time so anyways here's
another one
International dates alright all links to
these are going to be at billboard.com
or you can go to the venue website for
details these are all my international
dates for the first half of 2019
alright the following dates are January
4th to January 13th all right I'm gonna
be in Cologne Germany the next day I'm
in Munich Germany
that I'm in offenbach Germany then I'm
in Tallinn Estonia I hope I say these
[ __ ] places right Riga Rigga Latvia
Budapest Hungary Warsaw Poland Berlin
Germany Prague Czech Republic
and we in Austria I thought it's gonna
be in Vienna the [ __ ] is weird well we
in Ostia [ __ ] I'm sorry and then
and then and then and then then I got a
[ __ ] UK Scotland run started in
February February 26th I'm gonna be in
Liverpool never been there
she loves you yeah yeah yeah right the
[ __ ] Beatles the next day I'm gonna
be in Glasgow Scotland any virgins
Glasgow
remember that bond Scott when he sang
the jack live there Birmingham in
England Manchester on the 2nd of March
and then I'm gonna be in London England
for a return engagement at Royal Albert
Hall all right and then all right I know
all you [ __ ] Americans are fast
forward through this because you don't
give a [ __ ] through you April 29th I'm
gonna be in Reykjavik Iceland all right
which is gonna be my next little
vacation I'm gonna go there a few days
early take my wife Copenhagen Denmark on
the 30th
then Stockholm sweet and I've been there
for [ __ ] ever on the first of May
Helsinki on the second Oslo Norway I
mean those those are the first ones when
I was going overseas Stockholm Helsinki
also Lovelace places and then Amsterdam
was that my first maybe that was my
first one not Amsterdam I went to
Rotterdam and I also did the Kilkenny
Ireland festival those are my first two
international dates so there you go
and and then later on that year I'm
going to do a whole [ __ ] run through
Australia so next year I'm gonna be all
[ __ ] international Billy alright with
that let's get back to let's let's talk
it's talk about I don't know what I want
to talk about man other than [ __ ]
staycations [ __ ] rule let's talk
about the Ohio State [ __ ] Buckeyes
all right can somebody explain to me how
the
[ __ ] those guys are always in the
playoff talk it just blows my [ __ ]
mind
how will you ranked 10th in the country
and you're still gonna be one of the top
four [ __ ] teams
how come college football can not get
that [ __ ] right I don't get how you
can let up fifth over 50 [ __ ] points
to the goddamn Maryland Terrapins you
got a football team and their [ __ ]
mascot is a turtle [ __ ] drops 50
[ __ ] points on you they just tear oh
he's in it I don't I don't get it that
[ __ ] year - and they're the same
record as Penn State and Penn State beat
him head to head and Penn State stays
home and Ohio State goes I don't know
what the [ __ ] what they have on the
board there but once again once they in
and you know something I used to like
Ohio State but now to me that becoming
like the Alabama of the [ __ ] north
and now I'm just [ __ ] rooting against
him they get all these [ __ ] calls
it's kids kids it's [ __ ] ridiculous
so Michigan Ohio State is gonna be the
[ __ ] game next week I cannot
wait for this game I don't really hate
Ohio State but I just you know that
always bugged me that Penn State didn't
[ __ ] get in you know it's hard cuz I
love Jason lawhead leaves an Ohio State
fan so that outweigh that that that's
the one thing that prevents me from
[ __ ] hatin on Ohio State but you know
even Ohio State Buckeye fans you got to
admit I mean what the [ __ ] did this
there's something going on you're not
gonna admit it you know it takes it
takes a huge [ __ ] sports fan to look
at his team and be like you know what we
and yeah their dad that was probably
wrong there it's not like I [ __ ] do
that right I [ __ ] stick up for all my
teams I'm a hypocrite what do you want
from me I'm the typical [ __ ] guy
anyways Michigan Ohio State this is
gonna be the fourth time Jim Harbaugh is
gonna go into Columbus or staying at
home whatever he's goin in Columbus this
weekend and he's got to go in he has to
look and get it done he doesn't have to
get it done because there's no better
head coach out there so I think he'll be
fine but
Michigan is [ __ ] do all right
and I actually think that the that will
have the fact that Ohio State led up 50
points against goddamn Maryland is
actually a bad thing for Michigan
because you know I mean I'd listen I've
been just [ __ ] reconnecting with my
wife all [ __ ] weekend which has been
awesome so I've been like sports mi a so
I didn't see any of it I just saw the
highlights and their [ __ ] coach there
Jesus Christ I mean he everybody none of
that looked football-related it looked
like he [ __ ] you know his house burned
down his [ __ ] wife's left them I mean
the emotion then what that [ __ ] his
name Jesus Christ
Irvine urban Urban Meyer that's what the
[ __ ] it is
poor bastard man he was acting like that
[ __ ] guy that was trying to get on the
Supreme Court the hell was his name
Cavanaugh right dead [ __ ] like how
[ __ ] weird is that guy's life right
now Cavanaugh he's just sitting there
like what the [ __ ] was that what was
that like to get catapulted to that
level of Fame for something so [ __ ]
horrific and then they just like yeah I
guess there wasn't enough there anyways
get on with your life and you dream see
you later
like III what this has to be a name for
that cuz now it's like he isn't famous
anymore or he's quickly gonna go away
like that guy there they were going
after with her Shawn Chandra leave levy
right remember that and everybody always
goes oh yeah then 9/11 came and that
knocked that [ __ ] story off the front
page and wasn't that guy relieved and it
turns out he didn't [ __ ] do it so it
kind of [ __ ] over his whole goddamn
career but that I want is there a name
out there in the zeitgeist that [ __ ]
word that I've learned this week is
there a name for that that you have that
level of [ __ ] pay Fame for something
horrific
and then all of a sudden like you know
it just it you get acquitted or whatever
just [ __ ] goes away and then you just
sit me like what the [ __ ] was that does
it have a name it's got to be somehow
related to OJ Simpson
you know guide the trial of the [ __ ]
century everybody saying he [ __ ] did
it at least on the [ __ ] you know white
people were saying that country got all
[ __ ] divided then all of a sudden like
now he's innocent then that's it
and then he just [ __ ] drives around he
could have got his life back together if
he didn't kill two people that were the
dominant like as far as numbers like
population you know what I mean like so
white people cared so you know and white
people are [ __ ] everywhere for the
most part you know
so then OJ you know no Jay likes the
Gulf so he's got to run into a bunch of
white people you know he [ __ ] up next
time he does a double murder he needs to
pick a group of people that aren't
represented so well at country clubs
then I think he'll be able to you know
kind of slip back into society am I
giving oj tips on how to kill the next
two people I mean I think I am Oh guess
what I [ __ ] did guess what all [ __ ]
freckles did I went out and I bought
three pairs of slacks and I'm really
comfortable with it I'm 50 years old and
I finally decided that I'm gonna dress
my age I'm gonna look good I'm not gonna
lie to you I was looking in the mirror
you know I'm in [ __ ] great shape I put
a few pounds on with the staycation all
I ever wanted I put on a few some [ __ ]
calories I've had a few but then again
too few to mention I'll tell you right
now I am a beet salad eating
[ __ ] man that [ __ ] [ __ ] keeps
me on track you know that's a nice
[ __ ] wake-up call you know if I could
[ __ ] lay off the goddamn booze I get
my flat stomach back again but you know
I have a little hanging open for being
on the road you know the same way if I
went out and ate McDonald's I'm fine you
know I start craving that I was [ __ ]
hittin the bottle too hard so I got whoo
you know that's what's cool about
hanging with my wife but she doesn't
throw down the way I do you know
something she's just like all right bill
okay all right enough and then I'm like
all right and then she also drinks [ __ ]
that I don't like like champagne and
[ __ ] wine so I'm like you want
another glass of wine I'm like that not
really I like grapes but I mean how many
can you [ __ ] have you know it's weird
anyways the [ __ ] was I talking about
slack's all right so we went out and I
bought myself a pair of navy blue a pair
of black slacks or Nia kept calling them
trousers
she's like are they gonna hem your
trousers right which always reminds me
of that [ __ ] louis c.k joke when he
was talking about whenever he would call
phone sex he would always get that
eighty year old woman on the phone going
I'm taking off your trousers anyways
yeah and I gotta admit last night I wore
my [ __ ] my trousers on stage and at a
benefit for the American Legion out here
and I had a sport coat on the whole
[ __ ] thing just dress my god damage
and other than being a little more hot
on stage because I basically was wearing
a jacket
I like there's our name for that talking
through a yawn and that dad used to
always do that hey guys you know I'll
tell you about you know have a good show
tonight but anyways I did a show last
night for John sites the American Legion
me and it started off it was just gonna
be me and Joe DeRosa
he goes you know to raise some money for
the veteran
and all of that [ __ ] and so I was like
yeah man I'd love to do it in this
[ __ ] place I always forget that the
number of it
it's American Legion forget but it's a
legendary one and the main room they're
like everybody from like Led Zeppelin to
like Humphrey Bogart has been in there
like Zeppelin I guess one time after one
of their gigs at the form of some ended
up chilling out there possibly jamming
or something I don't know what but they
used to have like you know rallies and
stuff stay away back in the daylight
goes back to like World War one and and
they have like all of this stuff
upstairs all this like memorabilia it's
weird right for wars and stuff like
weaponry and all that type of shits
really [ __ ] amazing so it started off
you know where John was just like hey
you know you and DeRozan want to come
down and you know we always go down
there and [ __ ] and he goes we'll make
you [ __ ] honorary members and all
that but they get the [ __ ] out of here
we can't be members we're not veterans
they're like no no no no no well [ __ ]
you know we have guys like you that
never did [ __ ] that we actually give you
a little [ __ ] one of those Cub Scout
army hats you know sort of like and we
were laughing like oh yeah we'll [ __ ]
do it so next time I talk to Johnny goes
alright listen it got a little bigger
Kael W Klos got behind it the radio
station and then next thing you know
we're doing a comedy show upstairs and
after the comedy show downstairs and the
vit the [ __ ] Eagles of Death Metal
you know I'm gonna play a show I was
like get the [ __ ] out of here you
kidding me he goes yeah now and he was
just like you know hey you know they're
saying they'll jam with you if you want
to do a song and like I just didn't have
a time I didn't have time to get
something together or whatever and I
also just wanted to go down and and just
watch the band because I've always
wanted to see them I there's so many
[ __ ] bands I've always wanted to see
live it's just I'm always on the goddamn
Road so and it's always like hey we
haven't we have a show out here and it's
like oh yeah when's your show and it's
always right
as I [ __ ] you know leaf you know so I
miss everything so anyways I finally got
to see Jesse Hughes [ __ ] live man and
AM Taemin and when I won the [ __ ]
greatest front men I've ever seen in my
life
the way he was performing downstairs and
by the way downstairs in this American
Legion that bar was when they did the
scene in the shining went when Jack
Nicholson was talking to the bartender
the shot that's over his shoulder from
the the bartenders peeled the point of
view in the business there was actually
up whatever the [ __ ] they shot in Oregon
I forget where they shot it but like but
that when they did his over for the bar
they shot it down there so that's the
bar over in the corner and then on the
stage the Eagles of Death Metal a plan
and dude Jesse Hughes was was like the
performance he put on he would have
murdered at Madison Square Garden and he
was downstairs in front of like a
hundred and twenty people just [ __ ]
pouring sweat [ __ ] just you know all
the frontman moves he was so [ __ ]
good at one point I just started
laughing like I don't [ __ ] do I even
consider myself a performer when there's
a guy like this out here then he had
this badass chick on bass the drummer
was [ __ ] kick all they had for drums
was to think that it was a bass drum a
floor tom and a snare like questlove's
set up back in the day and and the
amount of music that that drummer got
out of it it just it was just it was
[ __ ] unbelievable and I got to to
meet some of the people in the band
afterwards it was uh really was a
incredible night I tell you man you know
I'm not gonna let you man my life does
not suck so anyways dude look at that
[ __ ] score man the [ __ ] Colts
absolutely smoked the Titans and the
Titans absolutely smoked the Patriots
and I believe we beat the Colts like how
to [ __ ] do you bet how does anybody
[ __ ] gamba
on the NFL this year me that doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense there's like no
consistency anyways it's Thanksgiving
everybody it's Thanksgiving and guess
what I got a new [ __ ] I got a new
person that I've been following on well
I can't follow him on YouTube because I
don't can't figure out how to [ __ ]
figure out what my password is so it
always tells me to sign in it's a big
pain in the ass but it's this guy Johnny
he's but it's spelt the Italian way and
he's an out of San Francisco and he goes
like it looks like almost like it almost
looks like Giovanni kinda I have a mild
dyslexia so I can't quite remember how
it's spelt but he just goes by Johnny
and he goes like Jose he's like my name
is Johnny I live on the hill oh here it
is dot G I a NN I North Beach alright so
it looks like Jionni but he says Johnny
and he starts all this [ __ ] this guy
is such an incredible listen to this
[ __ ] I'll just plays this is his intro
let me see if this will play wait a
minute wait a minute I love this [ __ ]
guy but every day I go down to the
village to buy the food that I'm gonna
welcome to what's left of the
italian-american neighborhood in San
Francisco and that's it right there and
he's just staring into the camera like
this guy's just a [ __ ] real deal and
I've been threatening for [ __ ] years
now - I was gonna make a Sunday gravy
and I watched him make his and now I
have the confidence but dude he's got
these [ __ ] garlic mashed potatoes
that he made his eggplant parmesan and I
just been like sitting here watching
this [ __ ] and I was looking at his
potatoes it's like man I'm gonna [ __ ]
make those four for Thanksgiving you got
it's just I spit is is what is it Jionni
GI Ani North Beach you got to look up as
[ __ ] garlic mashed potatoes they look
unbelievable do you have that a little
bit of Turkey some stuffing cranberry
sauce you [ __ ] kidding me it's over
you're gonna have a great great goddamn
Thanksgiving so anyways I've just been
sitting here watching all of that [ __ ]
and then I was watching his [ __ ]
thing I don't know how I'm gonna be able
to do this [ __ ] justice I might have
to just put up the clip but I end up
watching this other random guy this
Canadian dude who was smoking and
drinking while he's cooking and he was
making a Sunday gravy and his apartment
was hot as [ __ ] and he had the fan going
and he was dropping like he think I
cursed this guy was dropping f-bombs
like he can't believe and then out of
nowhere he just starts telling this
story about this one of the things that
I hate the most about human behavior
other than war and all the dumb [ __ ]
that we do the obvious dumb [ __ ] is when
you're next in line and someone's trying
to creep in the side just to [ __ ] ask
a quick question
like nothing gets my [ __ ] blood going
right so he tells this hilarious story
about how this woman's angling in and
how he [ __ ] him basically made a quick
move and [ __ ] got both his four
up on the desk and then the lady goes
he's just random he takes a smoke break
tells the story he goes then she goes
excuse me sir I think I'm next and he's
like oh that's the way you have it wrong
because if you are next you be standing
where I was standing
and then he did an edit and it just cuts
to him going back to cooking he's got
the cigarette dangling in his mouth that
he goes you pushy [ __ ] [ __ ] gonna try
to [ __ ] with me on a hot [ __ ] day
when I'm trying to get Mike drugs to my
doctor because you [ __ ] wait like
everybody else you fat [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then he just goes anyway goes back to
cooking I must have sent that clip to
like [ __ ] 20 people my wife obviously
didn't find it as funny as I did but I
don't know they just I don't know you
know kills me I see I called in Kathleen
Madigan's this serious radio show and
Gaffigan was on and Lewis Black was on
and it was [ __ ] hilarious because I
was telling them how much I like to cook
and all of that and they were all going
like oh my god I had no idea like this
is just this is so this is almost weird
to hear that you're into this type of
stuff like I think like they're like
most people that they just think I'm
this angry guy I have anger issues and I
wish people didn't think I hate that
people think that I I mean I'm it's my
fault that people think that but I hate
that people think that I just walk
around like okay I could [ __ ]
all I don't I mean that's just how I
react to most social situations
so I guess does that make me an angry
guy I don't know I don't [ __ ] know
but I was kind of like I was loving
talking to those because I'm a huge fan
of all of them but I was like taken
aback like wow they like they really
think I'm a [ __ ] psycho
and I don't know I haven't really done
anything to make them think otherwise so
I guess I got to own it anyways alright
let's plow ahead here I'm gonna breed
I'm gonna read some of the yeah advert
advertisements here for the week alright
and then you know what I'm gonna do as a
special [ __ ] treat well I'll see I'll
see if Mia wants to do it although I'm
gonna I'm gonna ask her while I'm on cuz
I'll hit pause I'm not gonna be a dick
hang on a second alright she said yes
okay she's gonna be here for the
questions okay alright
oh look who's the oh Jesus Christ we
starting right off with the classic
right but oh don't do me on these
biondi's make yourself some garlic
potatoes doo doo doo doo me undies me
undies not the rhymes with potatoes
don't stick them in your underwear with
the garlic and have your wife lick your
balls on a staycation she'll [ __ ]
hate you
Wow Jesus you know it's not not off
tonight [ __ ] this song up but you know
you got to say the effort was there me
undies everybody this year this is this
is the year that you finally tackle your
holiday shopping early and guess what
you can get everything you need for you
and your loved ones at me undies what do
we get doing here me undies okay you're
clearly a stocking stuffer alright
you're a you're a [ __ ] aperitif
alright you're you're you're an entree
Union at the [ __ ] main course so call
you dumb Americans entree means enter
okay with the dumb [ __ ] that say you're
entering the meal okay it's the main
[ __ ] course I don't know how over
here in the United States it started
being called the entree you go to France
where that word is from that they're
talking about the beginning the
appetizers shut up bill you're [ __ ]
arrogant [ __ ] alright ok fair enough
you're right
anyways but let's get back to me on this
ok you can't do ok what you can do is
stuff the [ __ ] stalking this is the
perfect stocking stuffer and that's
usually the thing in the
and were you like ah [ __ ] you know we
got to stick something in there you put
the [ __ ] underwear in the goddamn
stockings alright you don't put it under
the tree like you just got somebody a
goddamn Playstation whatever the [ __ ]
these kids want yeah just just buy
underwear for Christmas you want can you
want to see your kids cry you want to
see kids finally realize that there is
no Santa Claus do that however you want
to [ __ ] add some accoutrement do you
[ __ ] Christmas you go to god damn me
undies there we go
alright me undies uses the coveted it's
coveted now micro modal modal fabric
which is three times softer than cotton
if you ever if you never felt this
fabric get ready to experience pure
bliss and underwear form you could also
get a style that is perfectly suited for
you men and women can each choose from
four different cuts all of which are
available from classic colors too
adventurous prints meow talk about
holiday prints feel free to improvise
you know [ __ ] if you want a turkey on
your balls or on your ass maybe that
could be cool I mean it'll be a little
weird if you wore it in March but I mean
I don't know about you guys I eat turkey
all year is that good all right speaking
of prints this holiday season the undies
will be releasing a new print every
Tuesday that means you'll have no excuse
not to celebrate the holiday right down
to your very core but why stop at undies
this year me undies is launching their
holiday prints and lounge pants and
onesies as well both are made from the
same micro Modell modal fabric as their
undies seriously how can you not get you
and your loved ones a matching holiday
themed onesie this year I gotta be
honest with you last year we got some
Christmas [ __ ] pajamas for my daughter
man and they [ __ ] cute as hell and
then if the parents have the same ones
and you take a group photo I mean it
doesn't get any better than that it just
does it
alright alright the undies has a great
offer for my listeners writing
first-time portraitures education
teachers when you purchase any me on
these you get 50
15% off and free shipping this is a
no-brainer get 15% off a pair of the
most comfortable goddamn under week
underwear you will ever put on to get
you 50 15% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies dot-com / / that's me
undies dot-com / / touchdown [ __ ]
Saints another up 9 to nothing the Drew
Brees and the Saints are looking all
right now look at all right there 8 & 1
I don't know the NFC South though I
don't like the D I don't like the
defense and that whole [ __ ] division
all right simply thanks right now you
can get a great deal on simply safe home
security system order today and you can
get that eating at 25% off any new
simply safe system that's an amazing
deal they rarely they rarely do anything
like this but they're doing it for my
listeners simply safe is great
protection for your home and family they
never make you sign a contract there are
no hidden fees and with simply safe
around-the-clock professional monitoring
is just $14.99 a month there's oh
they're always getting great reviews see
any t OC net I guess PC Magazine and
wire cutter all say simply safe is the
best security system there is that's
[ __ ] hilarious wire cutter sounds
like they're breaking into a house
rather than telling you how to keep it
safe protect your home today and get a
great deal on home security go to simply
safer calm and save 25% off your simply
safe system make sure to use that URL so
they that they know we sent you and
hurry this deal ends November 26
that's simply safe calm / 4s impl I SAF
Ebert calm all right how many more of
these [ __ ] things I got to do all
right well you already suffered through
[ __ ] two of them for no I got three
left let's do the third one we'll get
over the hump oh no these are also
written off these guys nice short copy
this is what I'm talking about vacation
no Olay ever wanted all right almost 2
million oh my [ __ ] laptop's gonna die
here
all right movement almost two million
webs watches sold in all over 160
countries movement watches start at just
95 bucks you're looking at $400 for the
same quality from a traditional band
talk about all the things you can buy
with that saved money alright now I
could do the math here okay so that's
three to five dollars left you know you
can get yourself a couple pairs of
slacks that relative up against you
balls as you want sachet your way to the
stage talk about all the things you
movement has sold nearly two million
watches in over 160 countries Jesus
Christ if you need help giving the
perfect gift this season but don't know
where to start the guys over at movement
got your back they did all the hard work
this holiday season so you wouldn't have
to buy curating their favorite styles
into awesome gift boxes and packages got
a love a company that does that huh get
25% off today during movements Black
Friday slash Cyber Monday sale with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement comm / / movement launches new
styles on their site all the time check
out their latest at movement calm em VMT
calm / birth all right
my bookie hey are you doing hey you ever
want to try to place a bit but didn't
cuz you're too afraid to pick the world
[ __ ] deep this Thanksgiving so the
worst [ __ ] whatever accent that was
supposed to be ever this Thanksgiving
it's finally possible for you to get a
100% refund on your bet if you lose it
what with the turkey day free play you
can bet the spread on either the bears
of the line if it wins you win if it
loses my book you will give your money
back up to 250 bucks
details supply yeah well I would imagine
you don't have to take that money and
roll in into another better that makes
no sense because you're not even
gambling these guys are trustworthy fast
and helpful so I know they're good for
it evidently new to sports betting and
have lots of questions that's okay too
because my bookies patient customer
service can walk you through any
questions you have about how betting
works that's hilarious
the buckin this is so crazy this is just
as
[ __ ] bookie and they actually have
customer service can I help you
yeah I don't know the under over or the
Tampa game okay first of all just relax
there's a lot of people that are
questioning this better sign up this
week at my bookie and they'll give you a
50% deposit bonus to jumpstart your
bankroll it's a great way to bank even
more money when you win log on to my
bookie right now use promo code burr to
get 50% off they'll put a 50% deposit
bonus that's promo code burr you don't
need a promo code for your turkey day
free play if you lose will credit the
money back into your account
automatically what are you waiting for
sign up today and don't miss out on the
gravy train at my bookie alright lastly
but not leastly stamps.com talk about
how the holidays are always the busiest
time of year yeah everybody's [ __ ]
running around buying a bunch of [ __ ]
for people you know no matter which way
you go if you believe in Christ or some
fat [ __ ] coming down the chimney either
way you're gonna end up at the post
office unless you have stamps come what
do you have on your holiday lists how
many errands do you have to run etcetera
oh that's what I was supposed to what do
I have on my holiday list well I think I
just got it three brand new pairs of
slacks
I guess I'm my own Secret Santa this
year look at that [ __ ] throw what is
that do you know the pre game of this
they [ __ ] try to say Carson Wentz was
one of the most accurate passers of all
[ __ ] time lumping them in with drew
brees why are they doing that
okay Carson Wentz is a good [ __ ]
quarterback but come on what are we
saying it drew brees is [ __ ]
unbelievable alright stamps calm how is
stamps calm helping you save times Hey
as you know the holidays are the busiest
time of year especially at the post
office this that's why we use stamps
calm it saves it so much time during the
hectic holiday season with all the time
and money you'll save stamps becomes the
best gift you can give yourself this
holiday season yeah you don't go down
there and stand in that [ __ ] line
alright now you too can enjoy the stamps
telecom service with a special offer
that includes a whole week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage
typing bur that stamps.com enter bur
alright and with that with that we go
into the questions and the lovely Nia
the lovely Nia I'm gonna come to you can
you turn off the Real Housewives of
Chattanooga first oh I am it staycation
all I ever wanted
I like those Saints uniforms man the
numbers look cool from once they have
this week nothing's better though than
the Raiders with the [ __ ] silver
numbers
shut up ladies there we go
I like that you were getting all
sentimental you're like oh my god this
is the first season of The Real
Housewives from Atlanta look how young
they all are hey gorgeous
I was just telling everybody how great
it is to reconnect with your spouse on a
staycation
yeah that's great all right are you
gonna get off your phone here and help
me out all right Instagram Jana Jana
Instagram chatter do you remember uh
when we discussed you know that woman
she started posting yes you know she
went from just posting regular pictures
to sort of you know not overly hoary but
she wouldn't show them to her parents
types of pictures yeah and then her male
friends who were in relationships their
significant others were having
difficulty with it and blah blah blah
blah blah all right this this one Mia is
from a lady okay
she said just dear bill bird just just
wanted to reach out and say thanks for
touching on that Instagram topic with
the female too close for comfort with
the husband I've been with my boyfriend
for almost a year and had issues with
his social media habits I'm 25 and he's
my god hello darkness you know he
doesn't have money to pay for food till
the Sun comes in the morning sorry I'm
25 and he's 21 and I didn't realize how
unhealthy it was until I was 23 so I
keep excusing it talking about his
behavior but it makes my skin [ __ ]
crawl I don't feel comfortable when he
snapchats his single female friends he
had before we got together because the
texts go away and they send pictures he
makes me feel like I'm not trusting him
but I would never do that with another
male and it's just not something I want
to have going on in any relationship of
mine I don't agree with 100% of the
things you say but I agree with a lot
and it was cool to hear a male
perspective on it that isn't biased
towards the situation especially yours
because from what I can tell it seems
like you have a healthy marriage huh we
didn't do this staycation I think you
were gonna kill me knew it took a weight
off my shoulders that I'm not
unreasonable for feeling uncomfortable
with it
love the show makes washing dishes more
enjoyable just a little though because I
hate touching soggy food am i right
absolutely you are soggy food is the
[ __ ] worst that's what they invented
those rubber gloves for exactly it
wasn't to save your hands hashtag
relatable Oh such a millennial yeah I
mean no but she made the little face
there with the tongue sticking out like
you know yes they know but I make fun of
that right okay yeah yeah yeah
your boyfriend's 21 honey like yeah
that's just like I said are you high
right now no I mean but
yeah goodbye hey honey no but he's like
I said he's 21 but you know emotionally
he's 17 years old and he's not gonna you
know he's gonna be like whoa why are you
becoming such a big deal
that's called gaslighting so all right
slow down
white person here gaslighting I know is
that like a black word that does not
somethin gaslighting for white people is
literally gas lights outside of a town
house is like making somebody like
question you know their their sanity or
their reactions to things when they're
having like actually a normal reaction
to something so she says hey I don't
feel comfortable with you snapchatting
all these girls here my boyfriend and he
said something offensive like what do
you tall like what are you freaking out
about like what a big deal yeah yeah
that's gaslighting oh when I'm like you
know goddamn well like she says she
doesn't do it with any of her male
friends if she was snapchatting hanging
out with a bunch of dudes he would
probably feel some type of way about it
so so for the other white people
listening it does gaslighting live in
the flipping the script world like that
was part of the English when I'm 50
years old ahem I've never heard that oh
just one away
it died my laptop died oh Jesus wait I
saw the next thing that banging the
neighbor or banging my neighbor what was
the thing in my room mate no you gotta
get to them I'm sorry now I have to go
onto my phone whoo there's no way you
look up gay were you in the meantime
look up [ __ ] gaslighting you tell me
when that when that came out because you
know I I could be wrong
God knows I am more times than not all
right these are the reeds let's see here
come on now watch this won't [ __ ]
load because I'm on my god there we go
there we go what the [ __ ] is this
oh um I you know something I I swear to
God I can't [ __ ] win for losing on
these damn things
great emails there we go there we go
alright let's get to the bang and the
[ __ ] where the hell is it
alright factory nuts did you look are
you looking up gas light yes oh yeah not
you texting somebody yeah what are you
freaking out about man I mean I'm just
hey your guests like right now man
you're making it seem like a nut all
right gas lighting herb it's in
dictionary manipulate someone by
psychological means into questioning
their own sanity that's in the
dictionary it's in the dictionary look
at that yeah once again I'm wrong I
apologize eleven warning signs of gas
lighting how to know if you're a victim
of gas lighting there's a whole thing
mm-hmm
yeah but it's also like a gas light
that's outside that you can't tell me at
some point wasn't wasn't at some point
slang and then the dictionary is that
guy not people are saying that's a word
I mean that that does happen right yeah
I'm trying to look at articles did Ben
Franklin started it was used in 2016 I
don't know when people started using it
but you're right I'd like yeah the last
couple years it's become a word that
people use to describe you know like the
word zeitgeist I finally know what that
means but here's a thing bill just cuz
you're just now finding out what it mean
this doesn't mean that it didn't you
know no no I'm not saying I'm well-read
but I talked to a lot of people and I
hadn't heard anybody say like all of a
sudden that that's the [ __ ] thing
people are saying alright what do I know
alright 15
little bit oh yeah you're like a
paralegal over there yeah I really know
how to use the Google alright factory
nuts listen lady
what does listen lady are they giving me
[ __ ] listen lady you keep regurgitating
[ __ ] about the Apple phone factory
Nets the people who died jumped because
of insurance payoffs fox.com had a
clause in a payout and the employees
contracts that states of Foxconn if they
dive in the job the family will receive
50k that's why all those people jump out
to give their family a lump payout that
[ __ ] xeno but here's the thing even if
they did well if you weren't so [ __ ]
underpaid right yeah
so you're basically you're gonna jump
out to [ __ ] kill yourself for a
teacher's salary and what yeah and
exactly and so what does that mean is
that somehow make it better that's like
no they're doing it because they wanted
the insurance it's like it's a horrible
thing regardless no they put Nets up
they put Nets up so they wouldn't jump
off and then they played soothing music
to try to calm the down and then they
were considering elevating their pay
which was obviously the [ __ ] problem
yeah so Google dead [ __ ] I'll go get
Steve Jobs dick out of your mouth and
stop trying to make it like you know
it's it's you know oh they're just doing
it for the pay out it's like what kind
of weirdo are you to even say that
that's fine that's one of my favorite
jokes my act won't white people that's
another thing when white kids together
like white people tell black people how
to behave around the cops
mm-hm just do what they say I don't
understand what the problem is why is
your experience not my experience
all right yeah banging my roommate I'm
reading the fallout as read by the
lovely Mia hey Billy [ __ ] did I make
sure you don't block the microphone down
the bottom okay I'm 22 years old in my
last semester of university and I lived
with one girl who happens to be hot I
found myself in the situation by only
meeting a four month term sublease to
finish my final semester a friend of
mine who was moving out of state to
complete her nursing play
when offered to sublet her room to me at
a very reasonable price for the quality
of apartment I accepted without knowing
her meeting my soon-to-be roommate the
hot roommate was briefed on me and was
okay with living with a guy fast forward
two weeks into living together we're
banging on the couch well that escalated
quickly oh there's somebody at the door
all right I'll keep reading we're
bringing on the couch
from this moment to about mid-october I
was untouchable insert picture of
Muhammad Ali after a knockout
it was around that mid-october point
where she decided to stop hooking up
with me because she started talking to
another guy from her home town seven
hours away where I have a problem is not
with heartbreak or heart feelings oh
come on now it's more with the level of
resentment on her side she's got a
really cold standoffish and
passive-aggressive with me it's to a
point where she goes to her room when I
get home we don't really talk anymore
what have I done how do I fix it
I'm not sure I see a future with her but
she's cool and I'd rather not have her
hate me she's a pretty laid-back person
and her mom constantly bugs her about
getting a real job she's a waitress at
the beginning of November that is a real
job at the beginning of November I got a
shot at a consulting firm which I worked
really hard to get
she didn't care in the slightest well we
were hooking you up she also told me
constantly about the other guy she was
talking to Oh baby we agreed to be open
but I found it a bit much looking for a
game plan here a longtime fan of the
show thanks and go [ __ ] yourself so what
happened they start banging somebody
cuts feelings what happened he caught
feelings even though he said where I
have a problem is not with a heartbreak
or hurt feelings yeah she basically
begged him because she was talking which
because she was trying to get over some
some guy while we were we were hooking
up she also constantly told me about the
other guy she was talking to right so
this was a this was a between guys bang
you know it's kind of like a buffer like
cuz you you're in between a rebound or
you're kind of wishing to be with
somebody else so you end up banging
somebody who's really into you and
giving you
the compliments and you know the dick is
right next door cuz your roommate so
that's super easy ain't gotta like get
up and get all dressed up it's like you
know you'll just take it because you
think I'm the best and you know you got
used you got played how did you get used
you got to bang a hot chick but you
didn't did you not hear the rest of it
like no I'll answer the door you don't
remember all right no he's up he's upset
because she just dropped him like a hot
potato and she's being really cool to
him and it's not really talking to him
that's the [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
over that's [ __ ] great and it's the
thing this isn't just who gives a [ __ ]
no no you got to bang this hot chick and
then she's [ __ ] she acted the way a
guy usually acts which is the best we
just walk away from it when they're all
over here who do you t-shirts right she
just walked away get on with your
[ __ ] life exactly it's done yeah get
on with your [ __ ] life gives up [ __ ]
you're 22 years old so perhaps you
haven't heard the saying don't [ __ ]
where you eat don't ever start [ __ ]
your roommate cuz when it goes bad or
when it's over very rarely can you just
exist and it's not off exactly that's
why it's [ __ ] awesome because now
she's just totally blowing them off they
live together and then it's like perfect
so I would just sit down and just say
hey listen I realized we're not hooking
up anymore which is totally cool but
like you barely even talk to me like I I
don't have any [ __ ] hard feelings
over it so like yeah you know you want
some Froot Loops
yeah maybe just try it yeah try to like
kind of call her out on being immature
about the situation it's like you don't
gotta treat me like [ __ ] now just
because we're not [ __ ] cuz that
that's illicit I you know I was sort of
teasing you before but it's not cool
that she's just rude to you now that
she's had your way with you she's done
with your deck so she's like the
greatest roommate ever
well she wanted to do was [ __ ] you for a
while and then she left what is the
problem she's on my Mount Rushmore of
[ __ ] roommates I mean the fact that
you got
Vanier is pretty cuz you could have
easily gotten friend-zoned she's
literally she's sitting there constantly
talking about other guys that she's
seeing you could have gotten friendzone
so you know at least you got laid
yeah Jesus Christ silver lining the
glass is not hatful the glass is full
and you bulls they're empty they're moms
all right all right condoms
hey Billy stretched nuts it's a lady
from Olay the ladies are all writing in
now I love it my boyfriend can't bust a
nut with the condom on wait please read
the parenthesis loosely whatever it is I
wasn't reading it smell let me read it
again cuz I'm not having fun reading
condoms respects are you talking to my
lovely sister I'm not but isn't it right
here where's the microphone but
somewhere on the ball in the Mona my
boyfriend came busting over the condom
on loser he insists it's because of the
condom you know he's like e right we got
into a big argument about it we've about
it the sensation is different duh of
course it is but when I told him it was
different for both of us he didn't
believe me
listen guys the walls / hurdles between
us work both ways it's like a pap smear
oh it went away
I don't know put in the password oh okay
it feels like a pap smear is it smears
that you'd issue the [ __ ] hours
you're a woman you should know what it
is or putting a beer bottle in my cooter
it's just friction you're one of these
I'm a talk just like the guys girls huh
by the way you look like someone
stretched in lambskin condom over
skeleton that's so mean
what are you learn to use about the
condom situation
my boyfriend is that we don't say that
word anymore if he is around maybe ask
her I would love to hear your views
still waiting on that
oh my god I love this email all right I
can answer this she's taking this
personally subconsciously because he's
not getting there that that's a
reflection on her he's lying to her
about busting a nut and a condom just
wants to ride on her oh I thought he was
already [ __ ] her with the condom he
couldn't do it oh I thought she was
saying my boyfriend can't bust it up but
the condom on so I don't know if that
means no this guy's like listen if you
just [ __ ] are constantly if you know
if you weren't wearing a condom in your
last relationship or you were in a
relationship but you would just [ __ ]
jerk it off with your hand when you put
a condom on it feels like you're still
wearing your pants all right and yeah
and if you know if you there's all kinds
of things that can [ __ ] with if you
watch too much [ __ ] porn you can have
performance problems as all that I just
think she's taking this like personally
I mean the fact that he can't bust know
with a condom on you know then she's
goes loser that's that's like not cool
that's like hostile yeah and so that's
like defensive that's what I'm guessing
because there's a bunch of guys dead
alike like a bunch of guys that like
[ __ ] are in long-term relationships
and come on I had that problem for a
minute yeah like so what you got it so
what you got to do is for him tell him
to start jerking off with the condom on
it sucks
yeah you just sort of get used to it or
don't [ __ ] do anything for like a
week or something and they'll be able to
really ready to [ __ ] a [ __ ] desk at
that point and maybe that'll help I want
to my doctor drew I don't know but like
but I could tell you this name calling
him and saying that he's a loser and all
of that type of [ __ ] is that's not the
solution also it feels like a pap smear
are putting a beer bottle in my career
it's just friction okay here's the thing
I feel pretty confident that this is a
male pretending to be a female writing
in because no woman would ever say it
feels like I passed Mia what is it's me
as me is a Yiddish or a beer bottle in
my cooter it's just friction women don't
talk like this
turn around with these [ __ ] emails
when they're fake no but sometimes
people also feel like they have to be as
dumb as me I feel or as crude as I am
listen guys the walls / hurdles between
us work both ways it feels like a
passion or prick what is just friction I
popped like no because if you've had a
pap smear you would never say that
I had one no you did it like that no I
got a complete checkup you did not have
made sure they check me for everything
fake letter fake news you say that's
fake I don't know I don't think it is
yep 100% okay
roommate ran someone over Oh Billy the
boner burglar there's another person
saying I'm not good-looking there's
white yeah this is the [ __ ] that you get
when you listen this comes with putting
yourself [ __ ] out there that's why I
went oh he's [ __ ] women go on then we
good the gut people would never say this
to a guy look at this person just said I
look like a [ __ ] lamb she comes
stretched over a F skeleton over a
skeleton brittle but it's funny it's
[ __ ] hilarious and I can't argue it
I'm s [ __ ] pretty accurate I just
know I don't like what I see no skeleton
I don't give a [ __ ] with that person
thinks I'm a good-looking guy and I got
a smokin hot wife so hey no that's not
bad not bad for a [ __ ] lambskin
condom in a beautiful baby and everyone
our baby's beautiful so take this so
that's it everybody likes us and we're
popular alright anyways openly the boner
burglar I'm a 20 year old get never ends
it likes it so never ends with stupid
people trash the way I looked at it has
no effect on me so it's actually kind of
a good thing they're doing for me I'm a
20 year old guy in and I say what I'm a
20 year old guy in and I stay with a
roommate I said I think that's a typo
and I stay with a roommate who was very
I was a very close friend of mine I'll
get right to it I took a couple of
mushrooms and was trippin my ass up for
the first time everything was great
until my roommate came in at the peak of
my high and said he had something to
tell me that was gonna make me laugh he
perceives to say he just ran a [ __ ]
over with his car and he said it like I
should be proud of him
bill his ignorance about the situation
was killing me yeah that's assault with
a deadly weapon aside from the situation
being crazy he thought this to me he
brought this to me mid trip he kept
saying nobody saw his plates and all
that [ __ ] on Jesus Christ with no regard
for what he just did what do i do bill
this guy really didn't give a [ __ ] he
ran somebody over and he killed my hi we
also just signed a lease fYI the girl is
okay much love to the lovely Mia over
there and the little one big fan big fan
there living with a psychopath you
should probably get out because if he's
can do that to a stranger what do you
think he's gonna do to you that's a
great point cuz I was just I was gonna
say she's alright well it gives a [ __ ]
like within the same sense not only did
he run somebody over yeah now what do i
do I really I really like how it took
also them doing it while you were
tripping on mushrooms for you to really
draw the line on the fight yeah sit down
with them big with cement well they're
young and dumb ya mean listen I think
you just need to sit down with your
roommate and just say hey listen man you
know if every time I'm tripping you're
gonna come in and talk about how he ran
I was over and ruined my hi this isn't
gonna work out so what I need to do is
get a schedule put it up on the
refrigerator you know I'll tell you what
I'm doing shrooms and then
just don't run over anybody that day and
if you do and if you two just don't
[ __ ] tell me about it till I'm done
[ __ ] giggling in the corner who are
you people living with who are these
seconds for roommates that you got
spaghetti
we're running people up for banging you
and then not speaking to you like you
guys need to make better life choices no
that's like well the first one it was
like a money situation
like she you know he got the apartment
because his friends you know blah blah
blah and then who are you people dating
is it like a pap smear a bottle of my
cooter like oh yeah [ __ ] lies and
stupid email wrong with you I know it's
hilarious I'm annoyed at this batch of
emails today I really am as you sit in
here watching rewatching season one a
[ __ ] in the Real Housewives like come on
and listen I'm a prick I'm alright I can
go at that so am i alright well this has
been the hypocrite podcast Nia how do
you write the staycation 1 to 10 10 huh
10 out of 10 [ __ ] great I know what I
miss my little boo bear so no but yeah I
think like you know we ought to be able
to do these this was good for us it was
great for us the best we've gotten along
him from [ __ ] ever yeah yeah it's
true yeah all of a sudden you can just
[ __ ] chill but just literally I mean
we wasn't twenty half days mm-hmm
nothing yeah nothing you stay and and I
would think wherever the [ __ ] you live
you could still I don't give a [ __ ] if
you live outside of Des Moines go rent a
nice place in Des Moines order room
service
yeah [ __ ] on everybody the waitress
at brunch today I would say no yeah
we're leaving tomorrow those ask me Oh
shoes you know working the shift
tomorrow because she was so nice
and I was like ah we're leaving tomorrow
she goes oh okay when are you coming
back and I was like see that part what
part yeah oh you've never heard that
before
that part no it's just more gas lighting
no no no that's like a that's definitely
a slang that's definitely an urban slang
anyway you don't have to explain it all
right little special language and you
can feel special got it all right see
see people you see why I need a
staycation
like I don't what happened to you you
would like so chill and relax they just
got the claws out are you getting ready
are you gonna go back you're gonna go
back to that when we go you guys don't
take it too seriously
just below hi hi I'm Dan no Brenda Oh
Brenda hi I'm Brenda I have to repost
this video on my my Instagram you guys
have to see it it's so funny yeah this
lady's just like she's 60 year old
Italian lady she's like 30 years in the
80s yeah this is an old like reality
show on Cinemax started doing skinemax
if you guys aren't too young to remember
skinny mags but anyway I'll repost it at
some point
hi go give the overall what she said hi
I'm Brenda hi I'm Brenda I consider
myself a sexy older Italian girl she's
like if a guy isn't giving me money or
what does he keep hanging up a picture
right not getting something from him
yeah he's not giving me money or having
sex that I don't want him or something
like that is to get out and I'm really
good at I don't want a boyfriend I don't
want a husband death is good guys who
almost dying I like them in favors if
they don't have any relatives no that's
why having relatives it's great because
then I get all the money that's my
favorite part
[Laughter]
all right that's the podcast for this
week
I don't know everybody have a happy
Thanksgiving thank you so much everybody
yep thank you so much for everybody who
came out to all my shows and you ever
ever get a chance to see the Eagles of
Death Metal live Wow I'm telling you
yeah okay he was late was like he was at
Wembley Stadium
his energy yeah I was gonna say his
energy was like they were at a stadium
and he came off stage just pouring sweat
he just gave me oh man that guy is is
like there's so many [ __ ] people that
get on stage and call themselves
entertained they need to go [ __ ] see
that guy and be like that's that's
that's the way it's done I always even
sitting there being like Jesus Christ I
should have been working harder up there
with my slacks and bills this gentleman
last night and he had to be in his 40s
or something his jeans were so baggy and
they were just pulling around his ankles
around his like old sneakers his blazer
was like down like past his butt it was
just like it was just like a sloppy mess
and I'm like I bet this person is
actually like a nice person but it's
like you got to get it together I'm not
trying to be shallow I thought like
looks or everything but there are a lot
of it I feel that just only being a dad
for almost two years now I can look at
dads at malls and I can look at their
jeans and I know how old their oldest
kid is like guys who had kids in like
the mid-2000s have like shaded true
religion James
oh my god oh you know it's all like sort
of like white in the front on the side
yeah all baggy and the big stupid
stitched horseshoe in the back because
those things were like [ __ ] loud even
when they came out yes
Bobby Kelly rich vos they that was just
like those things used to where true
religion jeans like everyday and he was
so proud of a natural religion he'd
[ __ ] pull the tag out my god they
were bootcut yeah and then guys have
guys ten years older than them they
actually had jeans like when you just
bought Levi's right so they show up and
they have like like Kenny
club soda Kenny club soda Kenny shows up
with the jeans that I wore when I used
to listen to [ __ ] heavy-metal really
is G these jeans are just jeans just
yeah just jeans no passion no style just
just functional denim and then what
happened now is his pants I never
thought after they got baggy they'd
become tight again but yesterday we were
out there at the [ __ ] mall mm-hmm and
how tight were that got that guy's
[ __ ] put you could almost see his
ball bag from behind I was [ __ ]
crying laughing yeah and now you show
like your ankles everybody's like
walking around like they're gonna start
moonwalking and we need to see your
socks like gold MJ back in the day all
right I can't make this thing too long I
gotta I gotta get I gotta enjoy my last
half a [ __ ] day of the staycation Amy
it's nice to love one another again
isn't it alright you guys have a great
Thanksgiving and I'll talk to you later
on and and even if you're a passive fan
of football you got to watch Michigan
OSU it's gonna it's gonna be a barn
burner I hope I hope I hope it's not a
boring blow up all right I'll see you